climate craziness on full display in l.a
where mayor eric garcetti is begging
people to turn down their air
conditioners
while a heat wave scorches the city with
temperatures as high as a
hundred and twenty degrees the mayor
getting mocked for tweeting
it's almost 3 pm time to turn off your
major appliances set the thermostat to
78 degrees
turn off excess lights and unplug any
appliances
you're not using greg
i mean this is embarrassing they they
can't open salons they can't open
restaurants they can't keep the lights
on what's happening out there
one of the bare minimum expectations of
a government
is that it can keep the lights on and
this is an
incredibly wealthy state the people are
over taxed they're
handicapped by punitive policies and
they can't keep the lights on
so i have an idea when you think of when
you think of monopolies you always think
of one company that has the entire
market share right
and they get to set the prices but more
important they get to treat the customer
like crap
because you don't have any competition
right well california is a monopoly
in its mindset it's a singular left-wing
orthodoxy
that sets the punitive taxes and sets
the punitive policies
and the customer i.e the citizen in
california is screwed
so what do you do with monopolies you
break them up
california needs to be broken up so that
there are
smart areas of the country can govern
themselves orange county for example
they don't need to be hooked up with
marin county you don't need to be
dragged down by those
idiots we need you could split
california probably
four five different ways they'll still
be great places to visit you'll still
have a coast
but at least people will be able to
enjoy their lives instead of
this crazy nut-so stuff
hopefully we can gerrymander it so we
can get you know
more red states out of it um dana a lot
of complicated
factors mixed in here you have you know
record high temperatures
you have a grid that's never been
updated um
you have over regulation of the
utilities they've done almost everything
wrong
well i don't think that the mayor
deserved the mockery actually i think
that
they're in a crisis where they need to
flatten the curve so to speak on their
electricity use while they're in the
middle of a crisis with these record hot
temperatures and
asking people to do a little to do a
little bit to get through it i don't
think is that
bad at least in the short term it's the
long-term problem for california that
as you just touched on the grid issue in
particular
part of the other thing is that you have
all of these fires and
one of the problems that californians
love to talk about is climate change
what happens when you have massive
forest fires that burn two
million acres of forest it throws a
whole bunch of carbon up into the
atmosphere
and that's all happening on public lands
the private landowners are the ones who
are actually
you know replanting figuring out a way
to be
responsible and be smart with their
forest the public lands are not being
taken care of so california
has this real weird dichotomy right they
preach conservation but they live
in a way that doesn't uh match that and
then they end up with this problem
emily your thoughts well that's exactly
right it's this extremist position that
they've taken to climate and energy
that's put them in this position
so instead of relying on a grid that's
totally about renewables they should be
incorporating
clean burning natural gas to meet that
surge and frankly it's making
californians lives
miserable and putting their safety at
risk for them to have this
all or nothing approach to policy
renewables
or nothing yeah juan they're phasing out
nuclear and coal and natural gas
and relying on wind and solar but with
the wind and solar you don't get that
quick
burst that you need to surge and
transmit the energy when you have
a big heat wave like you do now
this is not about fossil fuels jesse
this is about the grid and i think it's
about
the lack of upgrading the wires and the
substations
i think dana i think that you have to
talk about how you do a better job and
that's why garcetti is right he speaks
as a community leader
and the community with those high
temperatures is having a problem
everyone needs to cooperate